how's the off season going for you
it's good it was a productive off season
i enjoyed it
i'm happy to be back in pittsburgh with
the with the dudes so
it's been good i was reading that you um
that you participate in a lot of
voluntary camps why is that important
for you to participate as a veteran
player
um i think it's important one uh
for the young guys that are here um
because if there's no older guys that
are around to kind of
you know show them show them how to how
to move and how to operate
then it's kind of pointless for them to
even be here because they're just kind
of they're going to be the ones you know
setting their own standard
um so i think it's important for older
guys um
to be there to set that standard to show
them the ropes you know show them our
routines
you know i'm saying because we've been
doing it for i've been doing it for four
years and i'm still
working on my routine so i think it's um
it's good just to be here to to show the
young guys how to how to do things
a lot of people see mike tomlin from
afar and they make their judgments
but what is it like to play for mike
tomlin and be around him
yeah i love playing coach t man he's a
players coach
uh he's one of those guys that uh he
cares for his players
uh he he wants to know what we think you
know say he's not the guy that is
that is his where the highway he's the
guy that um you know he's obviously he's
gonna have to ultimate decision at the
end
but um you know he's gonna ask you know
he's gonna ask hey tj what do you think
about this and make what you think about
this you know what you guys been seeing
on film
uh he doesn't really see us as lesser
than he sees us as you know people that
that know we're doing that work hard and
um no he
he trusts us how intense are the
practices um
from other places kind of compared to
the other places that you've been
um i mean right now everybody's coming
back and just getting back into the
swing thing but once
camp comes up comes around uh it's
intense you know saying we're
we're going full speed uh you know coach
t has the same i'm saying iron shoppers
aren't
so everything that we do is uh is good
on good it's ones versus ones choose
verse twos you know saying we're going
against
ben we're going against juju deontay
chase james the whole nine
uh every single day so we're getting
better it's intense we're all
competitors we get a little chippy out
there but
it is what it is what do you take from
last year's season
what do you take more from the 11-0
start
or the one in five finish oh man the one
if i finish
um you definitely definitely learn a lot
more when you lose
you know what i'm saying you learn where
you're weak you learn where
uh you need to focus your attention at
and i feel like last year we definitely
definitely in that one to five stretch
uh you know we liked execution
we lacked i mean we did have people hurt
but still we like execution we like
communication
uh we like the details you know i'm
saying those last six games so uh
that then there was all the the reason
why we lost i'm saying it wasn't because
people were out have more talent than us
or
you know messing us up or confusing us
confusing us
they were just exposing our lack of
communication or lack of detail
what did you guys learn from as far as
the playoff loss
from the browns man you know i know juju
was talking trash
earlier but what was the overall kind of
learning lesson from that playoff loss
um i would say one don't dig a hole for
yourself
you know what i'm saying uh defense we
were not there they scored i think it
was on the first drive
or second drive um you know they they
punched
they moved on they didn't even move down
the field they had like two or three
plays and then
one or two big plays um and you can't
let that happen to play okay
you know what i'm saying especially with
the browns their team that you know they
usually depend on
no driving down the field chewing up the
clock you know with chub
um but we let them get those big plays
and and
we made it a lot easier for them you
know what i'm saying so
we definitely can't do that and um you
know i mean there's the ball snapped
over the head can't really do too much
about that but
um you know like i said don't dig a hole
for yourself you gotta come out fast
finish fast and uh just keep moving
i know you were excited that they picked
up your your option
um why is this and it was no doubt i
mean that they were gonna pick up your
fifth year option
but why is this the right place for you
and what's up with your contract status
long term
yeah um i think it's the right place for
me one because they let me use
my skill set you know saying my skill
set is you know miranda guy i'm an
athlete i'm a smart guy
um so they let me move around in the
middle of field and a half you know come
down
into recovery and whatnot so i think
they they let me
use my skill set coach t uh he's a great
coach that
uh he challenges me at the same time you
know today he's asking you know what
we're working on today tonight you know
i'm saying what we're gonna do better
we're gonna get better at today three
nine um and i and i love that that's
never an easy day
um he's never gonna let me slack whether
vta or grady brown or anybody else
they're not going to let me
you know because i'm a two-time all-pro
whatever whatever
they're gonna that's more even more
reason for them to you know push me and
challenge me
um when in terms of you know contract
long term
we haven't been talking about it we just
signed the fifth year and
i'm just going to go out there this year
trying to play my best you know dominate
do we do and
you know whatever happens happens after
that you know you talk about them moving
you around a little bit i still think
they don't play you the way you need
to be played because in college that's
why i fell in love with you because you
were
so versatile you could do so many
different things you can play over the
slot
you can play one you can play safety you
got 11 interceptions three touchdowns
but
no sex my man we need some attack let's
get into the quarterback because i know
you look watch jamal adams you looking
like man it doesn't make no sense that a
safety blitz is that much
yeah yeah no i mean i mean i i could do
it you know what i'm saying but i think
right now you know what's what's best
for the team is is where i'm at
uh we got guys you know t he blitzes you
know he's in the games on
on sax you know i'm saying he does a
really good job terrell edmonds
uh in doing that so i think you know
we're good one two punch
we got other guys around us that that
help us out and um you know if coach t
asks us to move around of course we're
gonna we're gonna do it because uh you
know that would probably be best for the
team
he said so so um no we're willing to do
anything
but you know i think we're good with
where our roles are at
no doubt you guys lost some veteran
experience in the secondary
um some pretty good players how do you
guys how do you replace that
yeah i mean i mean it's tough you know
mike hilton and steve nelson
they're two great players uh great
leaders they they love the game
they they study the game um and it's
tough to replace them but you know it's
the next man up
you've been a part of this this industry
and you know uh
the locker room cycles it's crazy
um but you know you just gotta you gotta
teach these young guys like i said
earlier just showing the standard
show them how to move you know what i'm
saying we still even when we're watching
film
we're watching film with mike for
watching filming steve you know i'm
saying
showing the younger guys how we how we
operate and uh you know who's got to
film it it's just the next man up how
aggressive
are you as a leader on that defense
going to a guy and saying you know what
i don't think you're quite doing it
right you need to come over here and
learn some lessons are you
do you sit back and wait for those guys
to come to you no
wait no last year or maybe a year or two
years ago i would have could have kind
of waited but this year is a totally
different story
i'm we're always doing something after
practice we're pulling guys you know
saying all right let's work on this
today
let's work on we have we will go over
the notes before practice and say all
right last
practice this was something we need to
work on so we'll stay after practice
today
kind of do a little bit extra that we're
always doing something before practice
just extra
um you know i think that's where even
though we're not going full speed when
we're out there
not doing the extra work we're still
sharpening our minds what i'm saying and
that's
a big part of the game it's a mental
aspect everybody's athlete up here but
not everybody is um you know sharpen the
mind so
i think uh if we could you know like i
said if i have opportunity to pull
somebody to the side and get better that
way
then we're always going to do it now i
want to know i mean
sometimes you know i had to pull a guy
to the side and really jump up in them
and kind of yell and scream yeah if you
have to do that
any or you know it's still not really
right now not yet but it will have to
happen
it's definitely a camp you know right
now it's a little slower pace and
uh heads are a little cooler but once
camp starts rolling around and
season gets a little closer and guys
start making the same mistakes
we're gonna have to jump on a few heads
for sure
now big ben you mentioned big ben and i
played against big ben
his rookie year and um you know
he was he was a young quarterback what
do you see from him in year
18. how does he look out there bro
man he looks good he looks like big ben
he's um he's challenging us
i'm happy that that's out here man and
he's practicing
um you know because he's doing things
that you don't see from every single
quarterback in the nfl whether it be
looking or trying to look off
safety or but a little single hand pump
fake that he does you know saying this
little stuff like that that
uh gets us better and sharper than that
iron sharpeners are tight mindset but
uh you know like i said he's he's he's
been he's throwing that
this past this sharp chris you know
saying has lost touch
um but like i said i'm excited guy he's
out here well one thing that should help
him because this offense was so one
dimensional last year
now you get naji harris who i thought i
mean this was an unbelievable pick i
know a lot of people
screamed and yelled and said hey they
should have drafted offensive linemen
but i thought this was a great pick
versatile back big strong
young healthy i mean and you know the
kid i mean what do you see
well i love nazis as a man and as a
player you know he's a great dude
uh has a great story but as a player
he's a competitor
everything you just said is spot off uh
i love playing him he's fast he's
challenging us out the backfield
i'm saying uh catching passes going
against the linebackers and um
you know he has that that no you're not
gonna outwork me tomorrow
that's something that we love having in
the city of pittsburgh
hey man when i look at some of the top
safeties in the league
of course i look at you i looked at i
look at justin simmons
jamal adams i like them boys out in
buffalo
um tell me like who are your two or
three safeties that you pay
close attention to or that the guys that
you have a lot of respect for in this
league
yeah uh i mean definitely the guy to do
as you must
mention um i'd also say uh
jesse bates you know we play him twice a
year so i see him
all the time i think we have a very
similar uh skill set
justin simmons for sure uh he's a he's a
great player
uh same thing similar skill skill set
move around the field
rangy middle field player um tyler
matthew as well
just for his his versatility he's kind
of one of those guys that are all over
the field
uh just does whatever you need them to
um
i'll say those guys right there i love
watching the game loves
oh and buddha baker baker yeah you
almost forgot
yeah i can't forget about buddha uh i
have a lot of respect for him i remember
the first time we played him
uh i played him in college but then uh
we played him uh
last two years ago my first year was a
steelers out in arizona
and he was just flying to the ball every
every single play like
every single play and i was like i was
like dude that was nice you know to
motivate you
yeah not for sure when you see dudes
flying around like that definitely
like i got it i got it you know when you
when you watch great players play
i think great players you know emulate
other great players you know saying you
got to take away you can't be like oh
you can't be off getting all salty about
somebody else being good
like okay i could add that to my game i
could add this to my game so when i see
him flying around like that
i was like okay that's something i
definitely want to want to add to my
game too
now tj watt man i voted for him for
defensive player of the year last year
aaron donald of course got it
but this guy was outstanding like what
do you see i mean the thing that really
stands out to me is his constant work
ethic
practice you see it on the game what do
you see every day that makes this dude
so good so dominating
yeah i i say it's the same thing you
know saying he has that that
a mentality of um you know i i deserve
to be here
i'm the best at what i do uh and it's
for a reason
you know saying he's not a guy that just
kind of floats around the locker room
and feel everything he does he does with
attention he's very intentional on the
field when he's working
he's not wasting time he's not sitting
around you know when we're doing
walkthroughs and
he's on the field he's on the side he's
on the side of the field working the
back so i'm saying bringing alex hi
smith with them
you know working the bags working on
getting us his first step off the line
and um you know with that comes is this
game-changing ability you know because
he focuses so much on the details of his
game
who's that sleeper on your defense that
nobody talks about i mean we talk about
you we talk about
um tj but who is that one guy that no
one really pays attention to
that that isn't either an upcoming dog
or just
kind of quietly just a dog on that
defense yeah
um i mean i think there's a couple of
obvious ones
i would say cam but everybody knows
about cam hayward uh
i would say either tyson illua or uh
cam sutton i think those are two guys
that definitely deserve more credit than
than what they get cam last year was was
uh
he was like he was everything for a
second there you know i'm saying
whenever somebody went down he stepped
in
uh whenever we needed somebody to you
know move around a little bit he was
willing to do that
and uh he played well he played at a
high level he was punching out balls he
was getting turnovers
he was executing he's super smart
intelligent and uh tyson same thing
he's a lesser known dude but he's a guy
that he's going to go out there and do
his job every single rep
you mentioned um being all pro in 2019
and 2020
what is the next step in your
progression as as a pro
as a safety what are you trying to do to
improve your game what what is the next
step
yeah um i actually i wrote down in my in
my notebook today
uh because uh coach t you talking about
the minutia
of the game the details the small little
things of the game
and i said i said i want to master the
minutia you know i'm saying
and and i feel like with that comes from
mastering the fundamentals of the game
and when you play high level
fundamentally with retired with your
your beat up you know what i'm saying if
you have your fundamentals right you're
going to play what you know i'm saying
whether it be you know slowing down my
pace in the middle of field so i could
break out break sharper cleaner get a
better angle to the ball
whether it be you know not biting on
shoulder face and stuff like that but
just mastering those little things is
something that i definitely want to work
on because
um you know we all see the big splash
plays but we don't see the little things
that lead us to
those big splash plays so i always want
to master those little things
hey amigo it was a pleasure talking to
you my man and um
you know you just keep representing on
the field and off the field love the man
that you are
and um wish you all the best and i will
catch up with you during the season
brother thank you yes sir sounds good
appreciate you
all right
[Applause]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports